for more than 40 years Ken Burns has
produced documentaries about life in
America he's covered baseball the Civil
War jazz and national parks and his
latest documentary is an 8 part series
on country music a uniquely American art
form the series recently premiered on
PBS and is currently streaming on PBS
org
thank you so much for joining us thank
you I know and congratulations on the
documentary so I want to get right into
it yeah what do you think
country music teaches us about being
American well I think it's one of the
great subjects that we've ever taken on
that goes with the Civil War the most
important event in American history
this is a great story about race many
people don't understand the
african-american component to the
founding of country music the banjo
comes from Africa the fiddle from the
British Isles it's never been one sound
it's always been a mixture and I think
it's incredibly emotional when somebody
says I'm so lonesome I could cry as Hank
Williams did there's nobody on the
planet that hasn't experienced that and
you're tearing up as we're saying it and
now transferring that emotion here you
know you really do dive into different
topics throughout the docu-series and
covering the different areas of it
someone who is not familiar with country
music and maybe wasn't a fan before what
do you think is one thing that they
would take away from this film well I
think I made it for them I mean I know
the country fans will come along and
they might quibble oh you've left this
person out or you didn't do my favorite
song but I really made it for the people
who aren't aware of it and I think it's
just the emotionalism if you think that
country music is its own separate island
nation in which you need a visa or a
passport to get to any other form of
music you're wrong when Ray Charles was
given creative control of an album for
the first time in 1962 he surprised
everybody in his scene by recording an
album called modern sounds in country
and western music and the number one hit
across the country in the summer of 62
is I can't stop loving you a Don Gibson
country song and if you listen to it
it's a country song being sung by a soul
singer
[Music]
and then I don't really have to say
anything about little nas X which is my
life moment it's not in our film because
we're a history and we stopped at the
death of Johnny Cash in 2003 but if you
got a black gay rapper who's got the
number-one country song of all times
then it tells you that this isn't just a
segregated music anywhere in America
their borders are porous and that's our
strength certainly bringing us together
now you spend more than eight years
working on this project what is
something that surprised you the most
every day I mean I I went in I was a
child of R&B and rock and roll and so
almost everything was a surprise to me
but I think it tells you the power of
stories Charlie Parker the great jazz
great was feeding jukeboxes on 52nd
Street in the 40s playing country music
playing Hank Williams playing I'm so
lonesome I could cry
and the cats were saying is fellow band
members saying bird what would he what
are you doing why are you playing that
he says listen to the stories and we
know that music has certainly impacted
our country we have a corporate
underwriters Bank of America that's been
supporting our work for the last 13
years and just signed up for the next
ten years and they have a tag line that
accompanies their credit at the
beginning in the end of every episode
and it says nothing connects the country
like country and we need that right now
we're so divided everything is a
polarity everything is you know a
dialectic everything's about pointing
out differences
everything's binary when I've learned
studying the US and also the lowercase
us that there's only us there's no them
country music it reminds us we're all in
the same boat together